you actually just recently released a  video whenever you were a teenager you  were dancing and I think I mean to  embarrass people oh this is look at this  [Laughter]  [Applause]  shows me that we could be friends what  is your so we saw your go to dance move  what are your goat Xi's shoulders what  are you doing oh Lord I mean back in the  day is probably about the Cabbage Patch  you know you could rock out to the [ __ ]  or something like that running man  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  while you're going in a circle like the  Cabbage Patch me too I will not stop  talking until you subscribe to my  youtube channel that's right and I could  talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep  still here not going anywhere I see you  don't walk away from this